ينضم الينا من الخرطوم فيصل محمد صالح
مستشار رئيس الوزراء السابق ومن الخرطوم
ايضا معنا مجدي عبد العزيز الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد فيصل محمد صالح هل
اصبح التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي بحكم
المؤجل باعتقادك
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد بقراءه ما حدث في اليوم
الاخير لورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ومن
المؤكد انه لن يمكن التوقيع على الاتفاق
النهائي غدا رغم انه 90% من الاتفاق
تقريبا اتم الاتفاق عليها المسود الرئيسي
وعده قبل ثلاثه ايام ووزعت على القيادات
اربعه ورش تم قراءتها وقراءه الملحقات بها
وستلحق بروتوكولات اضافيه تبقت الجزئيه
الخاصه بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري وحتى في
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري نقطه الخلاف
واحده ومحدده ولذلك اعتقد انه لابد ان يتم
تاجيل الجدول ليومين او ثلاثه هذا تقريبا
ما سيحدث الى ان تحسم هذه النقطه الخلافيه
والخلاف ده قديم وموجود وهو ليس خلافا
فنيا يعني اذا حاولنا ان نقرا حول المده
وخلاف سياسي لانه تباعدت المواقف السياسيه
بين قياده القوات المسلحه وغياده الدعم
السريع ولذلك في ظل هذا الخلاف السياسي اي
نقطه صغيره يمكن ان يتم عليها خلاف يعني
مساله سنوات الدم هذه مساله فنيه كان من
الممكن ان يجلس خبراء فنيين ويمكن ان
يستعينوا بتجارب دول اخرى ويغدر المده
اللازمه لعمليه الدمج بما فيها من
اصلاح بما فيها من توحيد الكوادر
والقيادات بما فيها من توحيد القوات
العسكريه والتسريح من هم غير مؤهلين للدم
هذه قضيه فنيه هناك خبرات اقليميه ودوليه
فيها تمت كان من اليمن يمكن مناقشته ولكن
للتباعد المواقف السياسيه صارت هي نقطه
خلاف ولذلك اعتقد الناس تحتاج الى مزيد من
الوقت والجهد حتى يتم تجاوزها سيد مجدي
عبد العزيز باي عين تراقبون هذا المشهد
شكرا جزيلا اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم بانه
يستحيل غدا ان يتم توقيع على الاتفاق
الايطالي استند في ذلك على بيان الجيش في
الليل قبل الماضيه انه في انتظار اعمال
اللجان الفنيه التي تنظر في المساله
الفنيه في دمج
وتكوين الجيش موحد كذلك نقول انه المكون
العسكري القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
التزموا او التزمتاه بالابتعاد عن عن
العمل السياسي في الفتره الانتقاليه الان
ايضا الظهر هناك ان القوه الحريه والتغيير
والدعم السريع
سيبقيان ظهري بعض هذا ظهير سياسي لقوه
عسكريه وهذا ظهير عسكري لقوه سياسيه
بالتالي الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان يقول اني
اقف على مسافه واحده من جميع القوى
السياسيه هو الجيش وليس الدعم السريع لذلك
اذا مضت هذه
العمليه بهذه الطريقه تطويل امد دمج الدعم
السريع تدخل البلد في مشكله اخرى وتعقيدات
كبيره وهذا بالضبط هو خلاف بين القيادتين
وظهر هذا الخلاف منذ منذ وقت ان المكون
العسكريه كتله عسكريه واحده ولكن هناك
لسانين سياسيين يتحدثان عن المشهد السياسي
طيب سيد فيصل هذا هذه الاشكاليه وذكرت
انها اشكاليه فنيه كما وصفتها هل يمكن ان
تخفي في طياتها ما هو ابعد من ذلك ما قد
حقيقه يهدد هذا الاتفاق في المرحله
المقبله
بالتاكيد هي ليست تخفي هي من الواضح جدا
انها خلاف سياسي يتلبس لبوسه للقضيه
الفنيه كما ذكرت لو الطرفان راى ان قضيه
فنيه كان ممكن كما ذكرت يجلس خبراء فنيين
يستعيدوا حتى بتجاربه دول اخرى ويرى ما هي
الوقت المناسب لاجراء لكن القضيه الاساسيه
موقف سياسي بالنسبه الى القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع ومشاركه معا في انقلاب 25
اكتوبر
هذه الفكره كانت القوات المسلحه وقيادات
القوات المسلحه العليا يؤدون واجب التحيه
للفريق محمد حمدان حميدتي هم الذين عينوه
دائما لمجلس السياده هم الذين عدلوا قانون
الدعم
من ذلك
السؤال عن ان هذه القضيه التي وصفتها
بالفنيه هل يمكن ان تؤثر في المدى البعيد
على الهدف الاساسي من الاتفاق النهائي وهو
النقل السلطه من العسكريين الى المدنيين
بالتاكيسه تؤثر هي ستعرغل العمل لانه اذا
لم يتم حسمها ستعرقل العمليه السياسيه
كلها لكن انا المريض اقوله انه هي وراءها
هدف سياسي انه التباعد الذي حصل في الموقف
السياسي ضايق القياده العسكريه القوات
المسلحه لم يعد المكونه العسكري موحدا
ومنضبطا لانه ببساطه شديده منذ 25 اكتوبر
الفريق البرهان كان يملك السلطه المطلقه
التشريعيه والتنفيذيه وحتى القضائيه لو
اراد ان يضم الدعم السريع كان بامكاني ان
يصدر قرارا بتعديل القانون بضم الدعم
السريع باي شكل هو الذي هو حل مجلس
السياده حل مجلس الوزراء اخرج الحريه
والتغيير ابغى الكتله المسلحه عدل كثير
جدا من القوانين كان يمكن ان يصدر قرارا
لو اراد في ذلك الوقت لانهم كانوا حلفاء
لم يكن يريد ذلك بحل الدعم السريع او يعني
اعطاء جدول زمني
لحل ودمج الدعم السريع لكنه ابغى ذلك ثم
اراد ان يستغله سياسيا في هذه النقطه انا
اعتقد ان القضيه السياسيه هي القضيه
الاساسيه سياسيه هناك اطراف في الغياده
القوات المسلحه ترف ض الاتفاق الايطالي
ولا تريد المضي به ولذلك تتخذ من هذه
النقطه حجه حتى تبطل كل الاتفاق السياسي
اذا كان هذا هو الوضع كيف تتوقع ان يتم حل
كل هذه الاشكاليه الكبيره في غضون ايام
والذهاب نحو التوقيع النهائي في غضون ايام
كما ذكرت لنا
انا اعتقد ان الضغوط المحليه والضغوط
الاقليميه والضغوط الدوليه ستؤدي الى ذلك
هناك الانضغوط كبيره على كل الاطراف لانه
كما ذكرت في نظر الجميع انه القضايا
الاساسيه الكبيره معظمها تم الاتفاق عليها
فلماذا الان التوقف عند نقطه الجزئيه فنيه
كانوا يمكن حلها بسهوله عبر اجتماع او
اجتماعيا او ثلاثه اذا كان الحريه
والتغيير او حتى الغول
نعم تفضل بسرعه
انا اردت ان اقول انه القوه المدنيه هي
اساسا المطالب بدمج الدعم السريع وحله هذه
مطالب القوه الجماهيريه منذ 11 ابريل 2019
الفريق البرهان وقياده القوات المسلحه صلي
يدافع عن الدعم السريع ويقولوا انه جزء من
القوات المسلحه فالقوات المدنيه لو هناك
امكانيه غدا لدمج الدعم السريع وتسريحه
يؤكد انها ترحب بذلك في هذا تحقيق
متطلبات الثوره والاشعارات التي رفعتها
الجماهير في الثوره في ظل تعقيدات هذا
الخلاف بين المكونين العسكريين الجيش
والدعم السريع باعتقادك اين تمضي الامور
السؤال نعم تفضل سيد مجدي عبد العزيز
نعم طبعا انا اقول انه مساله الدمج هذا
هدف كبير وهدف رئيسي لانه مساله الدمج غير
معني فقط به الدعم السريع ايضا معنيه به
الحركات الحركات الكفاح المسلحه التي وقعت
عن الاتفاق جبهه وهناك بروتوكول للترتيبات
الامنيه يجب ان يوفى به صحيح الموقف الدعم
السريع ما قبل 25 اكتوبر كان في الموقف
الاخر لقوه الحريه والتغيير وسمعنا
تصريحات القائد في اوقات كثيره جدا عن
الانتخابات وعن ان قوه الحريه والتغيير
تريد تطويل امد الفتره الفتره الانتقاليه
لكن حصل طبعا تغييرات صحيحه تغييرات
سياسيه وتغييرات في المواقف وحصل التقارب
او تحالف بين الدعم السريع وهذه القوه
الحريه والتغيير كل هذه المعطيات الان هي
التي حتمت ان يتم الدمج قبل التوقيع على
الاتفاق الاثاري وان تذهب العمليه
السياسيه وتاتي الفتره الانتقاليه بجي
واحد قومي موحد يحمل فتره الانتقاليه حتى
مرحله مرحله الانتخابات كما قلت وايضا
طبعا تحدث الفريق البرهان بان القوات
المسلحه والمكونه العسكري والجيش الواحد
لن يخضع الا لحكومه منتقبه لذلك لابد الان
من مساله الدمج وان يكون المكون العسكري
موجود بوظيفته في حمايه الفتره الانتقاليه
وحمايه التحول الانتقالي وبالتالي يفتح
الطريق لتكوين الحكومه
مدنيه تقود الفتى الانتقاليه لمرحله
الانتخابات شكرا لكما من الخرطوم مجدي عبد
العزيز الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والسيد
فيصل عبد محمد صالح مستشار رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق شكرا لكمما